les derniers sujets d'organisation
c'est bon
voilà bon bonjour à tous bonjour madame
la ministre bonjour chers collègues
bonjour monsieur le Président d'abord
laissez-moi vous présenter mes vœux à
l'ensemble des deux commissions les plus
sincères pour 2023 qui sera une année
probablement dans laquelle nous aurons
beaucoup de travaux en commun à réaliser
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues je vous remercie
d'abord madame la ministre de votre
présence parmi nous pour nous éclairer
sur le projet de loi nouveau-nucléaire
dont l'examen a été confié à notre
rapporteur Daniel grimillet président du
groupe énergie du Sénat cette audition
est conduite en commun avec nos
collègues de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable qui devront
toutefois quitter la réunion vers 9h
9h15 ça monsieur le Président au maximum
en raison de leur propre ordre du jour
je remercie donc vivement de leur
présence le président Longeot et le
rapporteur Pascal Martin rapporteur pour
avis nous-mêmes commissions des affaires
économiques devront libérer madame la
ministre vers 9h30 je crois au plus tard
et 45 9h30 9h45 je demanderai donc à
chacun de la concision dans les
questions qui seront posées on va se
limiter à une minute par personne en
raison des des de nos contraintes
d'horaires avant de céder la parole au
président Longeot puis à vous madame la
ministre et ensuite au rapporteur je
souhaiterais vous poser plusieurs
questions sur la relance du nucléaire
car le texte que le Sénat s'apprête à
examiner s'il est
utile et nous sommes nécessaires
relèvent avant tout de la simplification
normative or la relance du nucléaire
présente bien d'autres enjeux bien sûr
celui de la planification du financement
de la formation de la recherche de la
sûreté de la sécurité ou encore du cycle
du combustible c'est en tout cas un des
enseignements majeurs de notre table
ronde effectué juste avant les vacances
sur la relance du nucléaire dans ce
contexte je souhaiterais vous poser
plusieurs questions tout d'abord quand
le gouvernement voit-il de lancer la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs sur
le plan de la planification de la
programmation pluralienne d'énergie
comporte toujours la fermeture de 12
réacteurs orseux de Fessenheim pourquoi
le gouvernement n'abroche-t-il pas à ses
dispositions réglementaires désormais
obsolètes sur le plan du financement il
existe en Europe des financements par
fonds propres par en plein emprunt par
préréguliers ou encore par participation
de consommateurs électro-intensifs quel
est le modèle du financement qui a la
préférence du gouvernement pour ce qui
concerne la formation la filière a
conduit un effort de redressement à
travers le plan Excel du groupe EDF ou
le plan boost du groupe Orano la
formation ne devrait-elle pas davantage
être soutenu par l'État et enfin autre
sujet celui des moyens la relance du
nucléaire n'a post-elle pas de
revaloriser ceux de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et du Commissariat général à
l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives quand enfin au cycle du
combust deux sujets restent pendant
quand l'État prendra-t-il la décision de
pérenniser les installations de
retraitement recyclage qui arriveront à
leur 50e année de fonctionnement en 2040
et pourquoi ne pas avoir évalué l'impact
de la construction de 14 PA2 et non de 6
sur les installations de stockage gérer
par l'endroit voilà madame la madame la
ministre les premières questions et je
laisse la parole tout de suite au
président Longeot merci Madame Président
mes chers collègues heureux de que nous
puissions nous retrouver aujourd'hui en
audition conjointe sur un sujet qui est
cher à de nombreux sénateurs depuis le
début de l'année nos deux commissions
ont été pleinement mobilisées chacune
dans leur champ de compétences par
l'importance et l'importante séquence
parlementaire consacrée à notre
politique énergétique
nous avons commencé par examiner le
premier texte de l'histoire de notre
droit entièrement consacré aux énergies
renouvelables pour lequel la navette se
poursuit et nous continuons aujourd'hui
avec l'examen de ce projet de loi
relatif au nucléaire le parallèle
s'arrête ici car les deux textes ne sont
pas comparables par leur ampleur
s'agissant du texte qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui je laisserai les rapporteurs
entrer dans le détail de la technique et
comme ma collègue je vous rappelle que
vos questions devront être très très
courtes parce que à 9h10 on quitte cette
salle nous pour aller
entendre le candidat
pressenti pour la fit s'agissant du sexe
et je souhaiterais surtout souligner à
titreliminaire que l'annonce de la
relance de la filière nucléaire par le
Président de la République à Belfort en
février dernier rond avec près d'une
décennie d'après un moment sur cette
question à titre personnel je me réjouis
que nous sortions de cette logique qui
ne m'apparaît pas compatible avec la
garantie ne notre souveraineté
énergétique et le respect de nos
objectifs climatiques
alors avant de laisser la parole à mes
collègues je voudrais soulever deux
points d'abord et ça a été déjà évoqué
pouvez-vous nous préciser calendrier
prévisionnel du gouvernement pour
l'examen de la loi de programmation
relative à l'énergie au climat le projet
de loi nucléaire risque de donner lieu à
des frustrations que nous sommes pas
amenés à parler de l'opportunité de la
relance du nucléaire mais plutôt de ces
modalités pratiques pour donner un
horizon à nos débats énergétiques je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez nous
préciser le calendrier de la future loi
de programmation car le calendrier est
fixé d'un code de l'énergie prévoit une
adaptation de la
avant le 1er juillet 23 ce qui me semble
difficile à tenir même si la phase de
consultation du public est bientôt
achevée
enfin je souhaiterais vous entendre sur
les conditions périphériques de ça ce
projet de loi qui feront que ce texte
pour lequel vous demandez la validation
du Parlement sera véritablement
utile pouvez-vous nous rappeler le
montant des investissements prévus par
le plan France relance et le plan France
2030 pour se tenir les filières
industrielles qui participeront à la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs je
pense notamment aux investissements
visant à moderniser nos outils
industriels en matière de soudure de
génie civil de travaux mécaniques etc je
pense aussi aux approvisionnements
matériaux critiques pour construire ces
centrales et à l'approvisionnement enfin
pouvez-vous nous préciser votre
stratégie et vos objectifs en matière de
gestion des compétences et des emplois
pour la filière industrielle combien de
techniciens ingénieurs et chercheurs
seront disponibles pour la filière dans
les prochaines années
comment comptez-vous mobiliser la voix
de l'apprentissage
pour créer de nouvelles vocations voilà
je m'en tiens là et je laisse place aux
échanges
madame la ministre nous vous écoutons
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le Président je vais d'abord
faire un propos introductif et puis
reprendre répondre très rapidement aux
questions qui resseraient rester en
souffrance par rapport à mon propos
introductif Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs avant toute chose je vous
souhaite mes meilleurs vœux pour cette
année 2023 et je nous souhaite d'adopter
des textes sur l'énergie qui soit
utile pour le pays il va en avoir un
certain nombre une année 2023 qui
s'ouvre de la meilleure des manières
avec l'examen de ce texte important un
texte qui vise à accélérer les
procédures administratives de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires en France et ainsi à
raccourcir les délais de réalisation de
ces projets ce texte permet également de
baisser les coûts de ces projets en
réduisant la capitalisation d'intérêt
ainsi que la prime de risque je rappelle
enfin que les charges de en effet que
les charges de capital peuvent
représenter pour un projet de nouveaux
nucléaires jusqu'à pouvoir plus de 50%
du coût complet d'électricité donc c'est
pas complètement l'épaisseur du trait
dont nous
avant de rentrer très concrètement dans
le contenu du texte quelques mots sur le
contexte ce contexte est d'abord celui
de l'urgence d'une crise climatique qui
menace nos écosystèmes nos sociétés
l'avenir de nos enfants d'une crise qui
doit nous amener à réduire drastiquement
et durablement nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 le
contexte c'est ensuite celui de la crise
énergétique que connaît notre pays notre
continent depuis l'année dernière la
guerre qui se déroule en ce moment aux
portes de l'Europe en Ukraine remet
profondément en cause notre
approvisionnement et fragilise notre
économie du fait de prime d'énergie qui
se sont envolés ces deux crises ont la
même cause ou en tout cas la même cause
centrale notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles qu'il s'agisse du gaz du
charbon ou du pétrole
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'ambition
du président de la République et du
gouvernement menée par la première
ministre et de devenir le premier grand
pays industriel à sortir de cette
dépendance aux énergies fossiles c'est
un impératif climatique bien sûr c'est
un impératif pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français avoir une énergie abondante et
peu chère ou moins cher un impératif
pour la capacité d'investissement de nos
colites activités et la compétitivité de
nos entreprises un impératif pour notre
indépendance énergétique et on le voit
elle est souvent reliée à l'indépendance
politique notre stratégie pour sortir
des énergies fossiles repose vous le
savez sur quatre grands et
indissociables piliers la réduction de
la consommation d'énergie avec la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique je n'y
reviens pas si ce n'est pour rappeler
que le plan sobriété que nous avons
lancé avec la première ministre en
octobre porte ses fruits 8,5% de
réduction d'électricité plus de 10%
d'électricité de réduction du gaz et je
rappelle que cette réduction se fait
dans un environnement où le prix de
l'électricité du pour les ménages n'a
pas ou encore peu augmenté on parlera de
2023 de l'effet prix mais à ce stade
nous sommes dans un horizon nous avons
le prix d'électricité le plus bas
d'Europe pour les ménages et pour les
très petites entreprises
d'autre part notre stratégie énergétique
repose sur l'augmentation drastique de
la production d'énergie des carbonée et
comme vous avez pu le constater c'est
deux piliers les énergies renouvelables
que vous avez projet de loi que vous
avez largement voté et qui donnera lieu
à une CMP que j'espère conclusive et
positive dans les prochains jours et une
la relance d'un programme nucléaire le
gouvernement recommande la construction
de la relance de la construction de
réacteurs EPR 2 la prolongation des
réacteurs en exercice sur ce sujet
intéressant de regarder ce qui se passe
à l'international nombre de nos
partenaires européens sont en train de
bouger aujourd'hui la République tchèque
la Finlande les Pays-Bas la Roumanie ou
encore la Suède pays connu pour son
engagement environnemental aux manifesté
leur souhait de se doter de nouvelles
capacités de production nucléaire ou de
prolonger l'utilisation de leur capacité
nucléaire existantes tout en misant sur
les énergies renouvelables dans ce
contexte le projet de loi qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui vient introduire
un cadre d'accélération du processus
d'autorisation administrative ce texte
ne vise en revanche vous l'avez
mentionné pas à décider ni de la place
de l'énergie nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique ni des détails d'un
programme de nouveau nucléaire ce n'est
pas un texte de programmation
énergétique ce texte a vocation à être
présentée lorsque la concertation sur
l'avenir de notre mix énergétique sera
terminée elle se termine fin janvier
pour ce qui est des consultations vous
êtes d'ailleurs invité au Forum des
jeunesses qui réunira 200 jeunes de 18 à
35 ans du 19 au 22 janvier prochain elle
fera l'objet donc d'une restitution par
la Commission nationale du débat public
de travaux de préparation de la loi et
d'une présentation je l'espère au mois
de juin qui donnera lieu ensuite à un
examen nous n'avons pas encore précisé
si c'est à l'Assemblée nationale ou si
c'est au Sénat pour démarrer ce que nous
savons c'est que la Jordan législative
que ce soit l'Assemblée nationale ou au
Sénat sont achetés chargés dans les mois
qui viennent avec des projets
relativement consistants de la loi de
programmation immunitaire en passant par
le projet de loi sur les retraites donc
je vous donne le maximum de détails que
je peux à ce stade cette programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie reviendra
évidemment sur la question de notre mix
énergétique c'est-à-dire la proportion
de chaque type d'énergie ainsi que sur
le dimensionnement du programme du
nucléaire vous le savez le président de
la République dans ses propositions
c'est qu'elle est sur ce que la filière
affirme être capable de faire d'ici 2050
c'est-à-dire 14 EPR d'ici 2050 avec deux
curseurs de décision six premiers EPR
sur lequel nous avons démarré pour ne
pas perdre de temps et ne pas mettre en
danger les décisions que vous pourriez
prendre sur le mix énergétique
dans donc six premiers EPR et une étude
sur 8 EPR additionnels
l'accélération et la sécurisation
juridique permise par ce texte permettra
donc de ne pas mettre les procédures
administratives sur le chemin critique
d'une construction de PR à horizon 2035
2037 c'est le calendrier dans lequel
nous nous plaçons elle permettra aussi
de réduire le coût complet d'électricité
et de sécuriser juridiquement ces
processus ce point est important car
notre stratégie énergétique est
climatique ne repose pas sur la perte de
compétitivité de notre économie ni sur
sa décroissance il est important aussi
que le coût de l'énergie nucléaire de ce
nouveau programme soit compétitif ce qui
est beaucoup plus facile à dire qu'à
faire je le rappelle aujourd'hui je
rappelle que les énergies renouvelables
ont un coût de sortie de l'ordre de 60 à
80 euros par exemple sur le
photovoltaïque et sur les éoliennes
notamment marine et que c'est dans cette
dans ce niveau de prix qu'il faudrait
pouvoir avoir un prix du nucléaire et
donc ça il faudra que que nous en
fassions la démonstration
ce qui est plus que 42 comme le souffle
ma voisine mais je crois que une enquête
de la Cour des comptes disait que déjà
en coup combler on pouvait estimer 49
n'étaient pas un prix déraisonnable sur
la partie existante déjà amortie d'une
nucléaire le texte ne modifie ni le
processus d'autorisation
environnementale ni le processus
d'autorisation de création qui traite
les enjeux de sûreté nucléaire ces deux
autorisations restent en place de la
même manière que les deux enquêtes
publiques préalables ça c'est pour
répondre à la question de la sécurité le
texte modifie pas non plus le processus
de débat public qui se fait sous l'égide
de la Commission nationale du débat
public et qui a démarré là aussi
il ne percute pas le premier débat pour
la construction d'une premier paire de
réacteurs repères II à panli qui a été
lancé le 27 octobre 2022 et qui
s'achèvera le 27 février 2022 enfin et
c'est important de le préciser ce cadre
d'accélération de s'applique que pour
les projets de construction de réacteur
nucléaire qui produisent de
l'électricité donc pas qui produisent de
la chaleur qui sont loc à proximité du
périmètre de site nucléaire existants
dont la demande d'autorisation de
création est déposée dans les 15 ans qui
suivent la première galation de la
présente loi cela permet d'éviter la
création de nouveaux sites nucléaires
isolés sur le territoire et d'être
compatible avec la relance de notre
politique électronucléaire sans
verrouiller les orientations en matière
de technologie de réacteur le nucléaire
c'est le temps long et s’élanticipation
15 ans c'est une durée cohérente pour
mettre en oeuvre l'ambition fixée par le
Président de la République qui est de
construire donc 6 + 8 réacteurs ce texte
devient donc pas cranter la technologie
des réacteurs bien que vous connaissez
le souhait du gouvernement de recourir
notamment la technologie EPR 2 puisque
c'est celle qui est disponible plus ou
moins sur étagère
ces précisions étant importées qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce que fait la loi
première élément il commence par rendre
possible la mise en compatibilité des
documents locaux d'urbanisme les
procédures existantes en matière
d'urbanisme qui ont bien changé depuis
Messmer sont incompatibles avec la
complexité d'un projet de réacteur
électronucléaire et la nécessité des
mettre à jour conduira augmenter de
plusieurs années plusieurs années la
durée de construction le texte permet
ainsi aussi de réduire le risque
juridique pour les projets du fait de la
mise à jour de ces mêmes documents il
permet ensuite de garantir le contrôle
de la conformité au respect des règles
d'urbanisme tout en dispensant de permis
de construire les installations et
travaux portant sur la création d'années
réacteurs électronucléaire et des
équipements et installations essentiels
à son exploitation cela permet de
réduire le risque de contentieux sur la
forme tout en laissant possible la
faculté d'un recours au fond sur la
conformité aux règles d'urbanisme
à compter l'obtention je suis désolé
c'est un texte horriblement technique
c'est pas
d'expropriation pour les projets de
réacteurs électronucléaires reconnus
d’utilité publique
ce sont des dispositions qu'on a vu dans
le passé par exemple pour les Jeux
Olympiques donc on fait là aussi un
parallélisme ce texte rassemble enfin en
différents articles au niveau du
gouvernement l'ensemble des
autorisations nécessaires à la
réalisation du projet afin d'amplifier
la logique de pilotage l'octroi des
autorisations par décret sécurisent
juridiquement le projet les contentieux
étant gérées directement par le Conseil
d'État en premier dernier ressort c'est
également un gain de temps et un gain
d'efficacité de manière plus subsidiaire
ce texte vient sécuriser des procédures
administratives qui concernent la
prolongation des réacteurs nucléaires
existants et clarifie la procédure de
réexamen périodique des réacteurs
électronucléaires qui a lieu tous les 10
ans c'est une façon de répondre à votre
préoccupation de sur la fermeture de
réacteurs nucléaires qui aujourd'hui est
prévue dans la loi je rappelle que nos
réacteurs nucléaires ont été construits
pour 40 ans que nous avons fait le choix
de les prolonger jusqu'à 50 ans que si
nous voulons aller au de 50 à 60 ans il
faudra qu'il repasse encore une visite
qui sera particulièrement exigeante et
qu'il faut surtout nous mettre en
position d'être capable de passer cette
visite puisque la l'orientation du
président de la République est très
claire pour soulever enfin lever cette
ambiguïté c'est de prolonger au maximum
nos réacteurs nucléaires existants en
sécurité
il ratifie non on n'a pas besoin de ça
puisque ça arrive en 2035 donc c'est
surtout on a besoin d'avoir
une conduite de projets et vous aurez
l'occasion de
mettre le décret enfin de faire ajuster
le décret dans le cadre de la PPE dans
quelques mois donc il y a pas de
problème sur le chemin critique de ces
décisions
erratifie une ordonnance portant
diverses dispositions en matière de
nucléaire qui datait de 2016 et vient
corriger des incohérences sur la
caractérisation d'un arrêt définitif de
réacteur là aussi c'est une réponse à
votre question madame la Présidente au
regard du retour d'expérience de
certains arrêts
longs résultant de difficultés
techniques comme un Flamanville alors
quand le lancement et bien nous avons
déjà préempté je dirais des procédures
administratives pour ne pas perdre de
temps mais le lancement la décision de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires c'est vous
qui la prenez dans la loi énergétima cet
été le programme
de la PPE 12 fermetures j'ai répondu
c'est fermeture seront donc revisités à
l'aune de cette loi que vous voterez
mais en tout état de cause nous nous
donnons les moyens de prolonger les
réacteurs nucléaires au maximum la
position de l'exécutif est sans
ambitinguée sur le financement nous
n'avons pas encore tranché la voix qui
sera préférée mais en tout état de cause
il y aura un enjeu de régulation dans le
cadre du fonctionnement du marché de
l'électricité européen sur la question
de la formation vous le savez nous avons
tous l'effort de la filière en fait est
accompagné et à l'initiative je le
rappelle
du gouvernement puisque j'ai moi-même
fait signer un contrat stratégique de
filière en 2019 qui comporte un volet
formation important qui est ensuite
accompagnée dans le plan de relance et
qui a été accompagné dans le plan France
2030 sur le seul volet formation par
exemple nous venons de valider un projet
de 40 millions de soutien de aux
formations nucléaires sur l'univers sur
la région Normandie en appui des projets
que nous portons surpenier et sur
Gravelines qui est à la limite des
Hauts-de-France
dernier point sur le cycle du
combustible et décision sur la
pérennisation des installations de
recyclage c'est notamment un des enjeux
d'un Comité de politique nucléaire à
venir qui devrait se tenir début février
France relance ces 470 millions d'euros
consacrés à la montée en compétences à
la mise à niveau de la filière nucléaire
notamment sur la digitalisation des
entreprises de la sous-traitance et
France 2030 c'est 2 milliards d'euros
qui sont
qui sont consacrés à l'innovation à la
R&D à la pré-industrialisation notamment
sur les petits réacteurs les SMS mais
également sur les enjeux du combustible
très bien merci beaucoup madame madame
la ministre on va passer aux
interventions des rapporteurs et donc
Daniel Gremillet et ensuite Pascal
Martin oui merci Madame présente
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je vous remercie mon collègue Pascal
Martin nous avons travaillé bien
ensemble durant ces différentes
auditions
avec un grand plaisir que j'effectue
actuellement mon travail de rapporteur
sur ce projet de loi nous avons à
travers des travaux réalisés qui étaient
très riche d'enseignement puisque nous
avons entendu 100 personnalité à
l'occasion de 50 auditions je retiens de
ces auditions en large consensus sur
l'objectif du texte qui permet des gains
de temps en substantiels mais aussi des
critiques sur la méthode
le gouvernement légifère dans le
désordre fallu soumettre un examen de
parlementaire malgré que ce que venait
de dire Madame la Ministre la loi de
programmation puisque celle sur
nucléaire puis celles sur le
renouvelable donc on est un peu à
l'envers par rapport à ce qu'on aurait
pu imaginer dans cette ordre de plus le
gouvernement légifères sans cesse au
troisième texte énergétique depuis
juillet avec les lois sur le pouvoir
d'achois d'achat le renouvelable et le
nucléaire le gouvernement légifère dans
la précipitation mettant le débat la
tenue d'un débat public en cours enfin
il gère sur la simplification sans
réponse aux enjeux soulevés par la
présidente face à ces difficultés je
souhaiterais vous êtes votre éclairage
sur plusieurs points
sur l'article premier madame la ministre
le chant de la relance du nucléaire ne
pourrait-il pas être étendue les
professionnels nous ont indiqué que le
délai de 15 ans a été un peu juste pour
réaliser le programme complet de 14
paires de au-delà des 6 par ailleurs le
texte
et focalisé sur ces EP R2 au détriment
des autres technologies en cours de
développement tels que les SMS les
électrolyseurs d'hydrogène ou des
réacteurs de quatrième génération ne
pourrait-on pas prévoir une plus grande
neutralité technologique sur les
articles 2 et 3 s'ils permettent de
regrouper les autorisations en matière
d'urbanisme la procédure globale fera
tout de même intervenir de très nombreux
acteurs entendez-vous consolider une
forme de pilotage interne spécifique à
ces procédures pour éviter une forme
d'éclatement et pour mieux coordonner
l'ensemble surtout prévoyez-vous danser
les moyens ou les effectifs des
administrations concernées afin de
garantir que les délais d'instruction ne
soient pas un frein à leur relance du
nucléaire sur l'article 4
si l'on comprend la nécessité d'aller
vite sur les constructions cela ne doit
pas être au détriment de la sûreté or la
définition des travaux selon qu'il
puisse être anticipé ou non me semble
perfectible ne pourrait-on pas prévoir
une définition plus précise le cas
échéant en permettant à la SN de donner
un avis pour prévenir tout risque en
matière de sûreté
sachant que des garanties prévues pour
l'étude d'impact et l'enquête publique
elles sont lacunaire ne devrait-on pas
compléter le texte en ce sens sur les
articles 5 et 6 il vit sa facilité la
construction des réacteurs en façade
maritimes dont une dérogation générale à
la loi littérale littorale si je
comprends
et bien tout l'intérêt pour l'exploitant
et les collectivités territoriales
concernées de bénéficier de ces
fassistes pensez-vous que ce projet de
loi s'attaque suffisamment à la question
des risques littoraux
de la vulnérabilité face aux élèves
climatis climatiques est-ce qu'il n'y
aurait pas des marges de manœuvre
supplémentaires sur ce point afin
d'accélérer la production d'électricité
nucléaire tout en tirant les
conséquences du changement d'époque dans
lequel nous nous trouvons sur l'article
7 sur la procédure des propriétaires
d'extrême urgence la nécessité de
libérer du foncier légitime pour autant
il ne faut pas perdre de vue les
garanties constitutionnelles aux droits
de propriété pourquoi ne pas avoir
repris les mêmes garanties que celles
prévues pour le projet ITER en matière
de relogement des occupants ou
d'indemnisation des commerçants de plus
le chant des travaux semble large ne
pourrait-on pas préférer une
expropriation simple à une expérience
une expropriation d'extrême urgence pour
ceux intervenants à la toute fin je
pense aux installations liées à
l'exploitation des installations et aux
ouvrages de raccordement sur l'article 9
sur les modalités de réalisation du
réexamen décennale pourrait-on pas
maintenir le principe d'un rapport
intermédiaire quitte à ajuster son objet
de manière à prévoir un point de
rendez-vous amis parcours entre
l'exploitant et la SN et ne faudrait-il
pas clarifier les conditions dans
lesquelles une modification peut être
soumise à déclaration ou à autorisation
selon qu'elle soit notable ou
substantielle et il nous et je n'oublie
pas l'essentiel la résilience des
réacteurs ou changements climatique dans
les démonstration de sûreté sur
l'article 10 sur la mise à l'arrêt
définitive des réacteurs les délais
prévus
l'appellent-ils pas être clarifié pour
faire prévaloir le DFX par la puissance
publique
dans le décret à celui proposé par
l'exploitant dans la déclaration enfin
c'est l'article 11 sur la ratification
d'une ordonnance la SN souhaite déléguer
davantage de pouvoir à la commission des
sanctions avez-vous un avis sur ce point
voilà madame la Présidente les questions
que je souhaitais vous poser merci
Daniel cher Pascal nous t'écoutons merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre plusieurs
sujets d'importance sont d'ores et déjà
été évoqués par la présidente Sophie
prima président Jean-François Longeot et
mon collègue Daniel grémillier
rapporteur au fond de ce texte que je
remercie pour son travail collaboratif
tout au long de cette période de trêve
des confiseurs
pour ma part je souhaitais vous
interroger uniquement madame la mini sur
deux points d'abord sur les délais de
réalisation de ce nouveau programme
nucléaire ensuite sur la notion de
proximité immédiate visée à l'article
premier du projet de loi nous l'avons
entendu en audition le projet de loi qui
nous est soumis va permettre d'accélérer
les procédures d'urbanisme et les
procédures environnementales nécessaires
à la construction des nouveaux réacteurs
EP2
le gain est difficile à estimer mais
peut-être évalué et évalué pardon en
toute état de cause à minima à plusieurs
mois dans une vision optimiste si l'on
prend en compte les mesures qui
permettent de réduire les contentieux
potentiels je souhaitais vous interroger
sur la période située entre le début de
la construction des réacteurs et leur
mise en service et notamment la durée
d'instruction des dossiers
d'autorisation de création sous l'égide
de l'ASN autorité administrative
indépendante pouvez-vous madame la
ministre nous rappeler les durées
d'instruction des autorisations de
création que vous avez retenu comme
hypothèse et vos objectifs précis et
dater de mise en service des premières
paires de PA2
quel regard portez-vous sur les moyens
de la SN madame la Présidente primal a
évoqué tout à l'heure en particulier les
moyens humains vous semble-t-il adapté à
la charge de travail importante du
régulateur qui va encore augmenter avec
l'instruction des nouveaux projets EP2
je souhaitais enfin revenir avec vous
sur la notion de proximité immédiate qui
est inscrite à l'article premier du
texte vous l'avez vu dans les
amendements déposés par Daniel
gremillier au nom de la commission des
Affaires éco et par moi-même au nom de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire nous avons cherché ensemble à
préciser cette notion en prenant appui
sur le périmètre actuel des PPI des
plans particuliers d'intervention
applicables à de nombreux types
d'installations nucléaires de base dont
les centrales nucléaires à côté desquels
des nouveaux réacteurs EPR 2 seront
implantés la définition sèche retenue
dans le projet de loi me paraît trop
imprécise pouvant donner lieu à
contentieux proximité immédiate on peut
beaucoup mettre dans ce dans ce vocable
madame la ministre pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur ce que
vous comptez inscrire dans le décret en
Conseil d'État prévu à l'article 8 du
texte qui a vocation justement à définir
encore plus précisément cette proximité
immédiate je vous remercie
merci
je vous propose peut-être de répondre à
nos deux rapporteurs
alors je vais essayer de faire très vite
ce qui me ressemble pas le texte n'est
pas focalisé sur les EPR 2 il a été
justement rédigé pour nous citer à aucun
moment une technologie particulière donc
ça c'est pour bien préciser le point
donc on peut recourir à n'importe quel
type de technologie en revanche il est
focalisés sur des réacteurs qui
produisent de l'électricité c'est là où
on a un choix technologique affirmé il
s'agit bien d'accompagner
l'électrification de notre pays
vous mentionnez le sujet de la méthode
je vais rappeler qu'en fait l'enjeu et
c'est une c'est un enjeu que je pense
difficilement reprochable au
gouvernement c'est tout simplement de
respecter le temps du débat public c'est
ce que nous faisons avec la Commission
nationale du débat public qui a lancé un
débat public sur le mix énergétique et
qui a lancé un débat public décalé dans
le temps sur la construction de deux
premières réacteurs él à la construction
d'un nouveau programme de réacteur
puisque le premier débat public sur les
deux réacteurs de penlit est un peu plus
large le seul objet de réacteur à
panique et en temps masqué nous
travaillons à mettre à jour toutes les
procédures administratives qui nous
permettent de répondre à notre objectif
de construction dans des délais le plus
tenu possible de ces réacteurs si vous
veniez à vous prononcer en faveur de
cette construction donc c'est plutôt une
anticipation et je crois que gouverner
c'est prévoir et on peut pas reprocher
au gouvernement d'anticiper et
précisément d'être à l'heure et de ne
pas faire des procédures administratives
des procédures grès sur le chemin
critique de la construction
j'insiste 15 ans 15 ans c'est le délai
pour déposer les autorisations c'est pas
le délai pour construire les réacteurs
ce qui permet je pense d'être plus
raisonnable par rapport à la tenue du
calendrier monsieur le rapporteur que
sur lequel vous vous inquiétez la
définition des travaux je crois qu'il
est très clair de faire le départ entre
les travaux qui relèvent du cœur du
réacteur le groupe par exemple le
bâtiment qui accueille le combustible et
tout ce qui est parking bureau
dalles de béton qui a priori ne soulève
aucune difficulté d'un point de vue
nucléaire peut-être la rédaction
peut-être améliorée ça mais je crois que
la vie de la SN changerait inutilement
la SN on vient de dire qu'on avait
besoin de
l'ASN sur les enjeux nucléaires je pense
que la SN n'a pas se préoccupé de
parking et ça irait dans le sens inverse
de votre objectif puisque ça retarderait
et ça complexifierait la
la mise en oeuvre de ce projet les
risques nitoraux sont bien pris en
compte dans le plan adapte d'EDF qui est
effectivement travail sur l'adaptation
changement climatique de l'ensemble de
ces installations je dirais même que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui peut-être le plus
compliqué je sais pas si compliqué le
bon terme mais en tout cas qui doit
retenir le plus notre attention à très
court terme c'est celui de la mise à
niveau des réseaux et en particulier des
réseaux de transport puisque les
variations de température et
l'augmentation générale des températures
avec épisode de canicule peuvent avoir
des effets importants sur les postes
sources de même que des épisodes d'aléa
climatiques importants vous savez que
sur la partie centrale nucléaire il y a
eu des gros travaux qui ont déjà été
faits notamment dans le retour
d'expérience de Fukushima puisque le
retour d'expérience de Fukushima c'est
un élément climatique qui fragilise une
instance une installation nucléaire
sur la question de l'ex-propriation je
prends le point et je vous reviens mais
effectivement j'entends la question sur
la question du rapport intermédiaire de
l'article 5 avec un point de rendez-vous
ami parcours difficulté des amendements
que vous proposez c'est qu'en fait au
bout de 6 ans on aura à peine à couler
le béton
de la première centrale donc on aura
assez peu de recul donc il faut vraiment
se mettre dans la position de ce qui est
un projet de centrale nucléaire où on a
des c'est vraiment le temps long dont on
parle donc il nous semble que ça serait
trop tôt les dossiers d'autorisation de
création prennent bien en compte dans
l'analyse de la sécurité le sujet du
changement climatique c'est évidemment
essentiel c'est ça sera traité
l'article 11 vous m'interrogez sur la
suggestion de la SN de prévoir plus de
pouvoir la commission des sanctions nous
pensons que c'est une idée qui est tout
à fait intéressante
sur la question de ce qui se passe en
termes de moyens de la SN monsieur le
rapporteur Martin donc il y a plus 6 et
TP pour la SN en 2023 je rappelle que
nous créons une délégation nouveau
nucléaire
interministériel qui est installé donc
dans mon ministère avec 15 et TP et que
cette délégation nous renucléaire elle a
vocation aussi à appuyer toute la
conduite de projet à la fois sur les
enjeux de formation sur les enjeux de
monter en capacité et en compétence de
la filière nucléaire sur les enjeux de
pilotage des de tous les permis et
autorisations et sur les enjeux
de régulation et de systèmes de
financement alors elle ne fera pas tout
elle n'enlève aucune
compétence des directions
d'administration centrale et des
autorités chacun dans son domaine mais
elle va surtout battre la mesure et
s'assurer que les choses sont fait en
temps et en heure avec la coordination
est bien faite en lien avec la maîtrise
d'oeuvre et la maîtrise d'ouvrage d'EDF
puisque c'est un projet qui va bien
au-delà d'EDF et qui suppose une
coordination impeccable si on veut tenir
les délais nous notre enjeu c'est que
c'est de réduire les risques sur le
processus administratif pour nous
limiter à traiter les risques sur le
processus industriel on a pouvoir on a
pu voir dans les ces dernières années
encore il y a quelques jours ou semaines
que les risques sur le processus
industriels ne sont pas limitées et donc
il faut nous donner tous les facteurs
clés de succès pour être au rendez-vous
et ne pas déraper sur les délais
les objectifs précis et dater de mise en
de mise en comment dire en service et
les durées d'instruction indacent ces
trois ans
plus deux ans maximum donc c'est quand
même 5 ans l'objectif de la première
coulée de béton qui est très ambitieux
c'est d'ici la fin du quinquennat
très ambitieux d'ici la fin du cadre qui
est là la réalité c'est que ça quand
même d'être plutôt la fin de l'année
2027 que le début de l'année 2027 en
tenant vraiment bien nos calendriers
et effectivement la mise en service
ce serait je dis 2035 2037 2035 c'est
vraiment sans marge c'est à dire avec
une exécution parfaite du projet
ce qui appelle peut-être nos têtes petit
buffer
complément peut-être de temps qui est
pour en tout cas notre programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie
proximité immédiate alors c'est un point
sur lequel on cherche on souhaiterait
conserver une certaine latitude pour une
raison évidente c'est ne pas devoir
revenir vers vous si on s'aperçoit que
une définition trop resserrée la
proximité immédiate
pose un problème sur un projet de
réacteur particulier on s'aperçoit que à
quelques un kilomètre près par exemple
ou
voilà on est juste dans une enfin voilà
on rentre pas dans la fourche Codine de
la loi
le décret en Conseil d'État il prévoit
là je suis un peu plus
décré en Conseil d'État pour la
proximité immédiate
ça vise à préciser mais on dit pas
comment le critère d'éloignement oui
donc en fait ce qu'on s'engage à faire
c'est de le mettre dans un décret qui
est plus facile à modifier et peut-être
je pourrais m'engager aux banc à retenir
les orientations que vous pourriez
porter de façon à avoir une flexibilité
plus importante tout en encadrant cet
élément dont je comprends effectivement
que il est juste de le préciser je crois
que j'ai répondu à tout là
bien merci madame la ministre nous
allons commencer la série de questions
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues pas
plus de 10 minutes chacun pour que
maximum puisse s'exprimer et nous allons
prendre avec l'accord du président
bonjour les cinq premières questions
Daniel salmon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre la
construction de l'EPR est une longue
descente aux enfers de la filière
nucléaire française mais rassurons-nous
EDF nous dit que tout va changer on va
attiré les enseignements et qu'on valait
très vite
comment peut-on croire ce calendrier
ces coûts qui vont être soi-disant
divisés par deux madame la ministre
expliquez-nous comment vous arrivez
encore à y croire sachant que certains
services de la DGEC ont quelques
questionnements sur le sujet deuxième
question très très rapide mais dans le
même sens que la question de la
présidente
EDF se trouve face à un d'endettement
terrible le grand carénage qui va
arriver le démantèlement qui n'est pas
vraiment provisionné qui va payer merci
la parole est à Bruno
merci président merci Alain
ministre mes chers collègues questions
courtes on l'a vu dans votre première
intervention et on l'a vu dans
l'intervention du rapporteur Daniel
grimillet la question du délai alors
rapporteur à parler de l'électro juste
vous avez essayé de justifier toutes les
étapes mais vu notre niveau de
dépendance et notre risque est-ce que ce
délai est finalement pas trop long
voilà qui est court merci Jean-Pierre
Moga
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
pour faire court ce projet de loi en
tout cas c'est ce que j'espère permettra
de simplifier d'accélérer la
construction de nouveau réacteurs
néanmoins je ne peux m'empêcher d'être
inquiet par rapport aux ressources
humaines qui seront nécessaires pour
mettre en œuvre la construction rapide
de ces réacteurs il existe une multitude
de métiers intensions chez DF comme chez
tous ces sous-traitants que comptez-vous
faire pour solutionner ce problème
aujourd'hui nous ne formons pas ces
ingénieurs si nous votons ce texte et en
légion les procédures administratives
concernant les ressources humaines pour
mener à bien ces chantiers dans un délai
raisonnable que comptez-vous faire pour
trouver les moyens financiers parce que
il s'agit bien là aussi de moyens
financiers pour former très rapidement
des milliers de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs et et également pour
attirer dans l'urgence des jeunes vers
ces métiers je vous remercie
la parole est à Stéphane demis merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vous avez parlé de temps long et même de
temps très très long pour élaborer les
stratégies or le 5 décembre dernier des
scientifiques californiens ont atteint
une sorte de Graal sur lequel la
communauté scientifique travaille depuis
un demi-siècle l'initiant seuil à partir
duquel la fusion nucléaire crée plus
d'énergie qu'elle n'en consomme cette
solution de fusion nombreux avantages
est-elle encore pour vous prématurée ou
regarder progrès rapides à concernant ne
risquelle pas de ce télescoper avec le
calendrier d'implantation des centrales
classiques
et pour terminer cette série de cinq
Frank Montauger oui merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame la Ministre
bonne année également
[Musique]
quand on regarde les
concernant la PPE excusez-moi j'y
reviens mais c'est quand même le sujet
un sujet majeur l'hypothèse de la plus
favorable au nucléaire de RTE des futurs
énergétiques 2050 c'est la n03 avec une
puissance installée numérique nucléaire
pardon de de 51 gigawatts donc dans 24
de nucléaire historique donc vous avez
indiqué vouloir fermer vous aurez
acteurs c'est ça dans votre propos
est-ce que vous le confirmez d'une part
alors je viens à ma question
donc dans cette hypothèse la plus
favorable pour le nucléaire en
proportion on va vers une diminution de
la puissance installée nucléaire de
l'ordre de près de 10%.
donc je voudrais savoir quel est votre
position par rapport à ça parce que ça
me paraît fondamental deuxième petite
question ou en est le gouvernement des
négociations avec nos partenaires
européens pour revoir la structure des
marchés européens de l'énergie et de
l'électricité en particulier et quelles
sont vos hypothèses de base en matière
le tarification pour sortir de la
situation dans laquelle on est et qui
n'est pas lié qu'à la crise
ukrainienne merci
[Musique]
c'est à dire que les réacteurs
nucléaires que nous construisons
aujourd'hui ont vocation à produire de
l'énergie de l'électricité
avec un coût qui serait qui a vocation
est suffisamment compétitif pour
rapporter de l'argent et couvrir les
coûts du projet l'enjeu que nous avons
c'est la question de la structuration du
financement
mais je pense que si demain
je demande à des entreprises de signer
des contrats à mettons 100 euros du
mégawattheure 100 euros du mégawattheure
je suis pas sur les objectifs qu'on aura
certainement EDF pour les 10 ans qui
viennent je pense qu'il les signeront
donc nous avons bien une demande
d'électricité face à un besoin de
d'investissement donc c'est un schéma
assez classique d'investissement avec
retour sur investissement là où il y a
un élément de complexité sur le
financement du projet qui sera à fond
propre et dette comme tout projet
d'investissement c'est la question de la
régulation puisque dans la vision que la
Commission européenne porte du marché de
l'électricité il y a l'idée que les
infrastructures sont accessibles à
différents concurrents et donc que l'on
peut pas être relié dans la même entité
ou en tout cas qu'il faut organiser la
fonction de producteur et la fonction de
distribution de distributeurs d'énergie
et c'est ce point là qui est un point de
complexité puisque nous point de vue du
gouvernement français on peut entendre
effectivement l'idée que EDF ne doit pas
être en position dominante sur le marché
de la fourniture d'électricité mais ce
qui est aussi important c'est qu'il est
l'intégralité des moyens pour avoir la
meilleure performance industrielle pour
avoir la meilleure performance
industrielle il faut avoir la meilleure
capacité à gérer l'ensemble des moyens
de production et piloter entre
l'hydraulique et le nucléaire l'ancien
nucléaire et le nouveau nucléaire et ne
pas contraint dans la mise en
disposition de ses moyens à d'autres
d'autres concurrents possibles donc ça
c'est une discussion que nous allons
devoir avoir avec la Commission
européenne sur la question des 15 ans
est-ce que le délai est pas trop long et
le 15 ans c'est un maximum qui vit dans
la loi c'est pas nécessairement notre
enfin si on peut faire mieux évidemment
la vocation à faire mieux si donc ça
c'est pour les 15 ans de dépôt de
dossier pour les 14 réacteurs que je
mentionnais ensuite la durée
individuelle de la construction d'un
réacteur qui aujourd'hui est donné à 15
ans par EDF je me fixe sur la meilleure
estimation de la filière
si nous avons des voisins de compresser
ce délai de construction il est clair
que nous serons ravis d'accompagner
cette compression je pense aussi qu'il
faut être attentif à ce qui a peut-être
pu pesé sur le programme de financement
ville si on fait un retour d'expérience
à ne pas vouloir au prix de tenir des
jalons commencer la mise en oeuvre du
projet avant que le design n'ait été
terminé
qui est probablement le premier péché
originel je renvoie des rapports de gens
beaucoup plus experts que moi j'ai pas
la prétention d'être ingénieur nucléaire
mais lorsque vous démarrez la mise en
oeuvre du projet alors que le design
n'est pas terminé vous prenez un risque
de dérive puisque le design continue à
avancer et que la mise en oeuvre peut
donner lieu à des hiatus et donc en fait
à des dérapages ensuite pour à chaque
fois recaler design et mise en oeuvre du
projet donc il faut pas confondre
vitesse et précipitations mais vous avez
raison de mentionner et c'est une
question qui a posé le président de la
République sait-on par les nouvelles
technologies que nous avons la
digitalisation le meilleur conduite de
projet compresser ce délai mais ça c'est
une question qu'il faudra adresser à la
filière
et c'est un des enjeux de je pense de
Monsieur le Délégué interministériel de
nouveau nucléaire
Joël bar sur la question des ressources
humaines je rappelle que depuis 2020
nous avons financé 200 millions d'euros
de soutien à la mise en place de
formation dans le nucléaire à tous les
niveaux que ce soit bac pro jusqu'à
ingénieur doctorant donc nous sommes
très conscients de l'enjeu de formation
le programme nucléaire dont on parle
c'est 10%
de des capacités de formation
d'ingénieurs de l'appareil de formation
français
dans un monde où on a besoin d'ingénieur
pour le digital pour le changement
climatique pour mille et un sujet donc
autant dire que c'est une ambition très
forte il y a deux enjeux derrière ça il
y a un enjeu d'avoir l'appareil de
formation il y a un enjeu d'attirer les
talents c'est pas que l'argent on
constate et c'est une bonne nouvelle que
dans les formations d'ingénieurs depuis
un an on a beaucoup plus grande facilité
à remplir les sections ingénieurs sur
cette spécialité nucléaire on a même une
sur demande par rapport à l'appareil de
production donc ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle c'est nouveau c'est
nouveau il faut arriver à avoir le même
le même la même attractivité dans les
filières de techniciens et dans les
filières d'opérateurs ce qui n'est pas
encore totalement acquis
et donc tout y travaillons et nous
n'avons pas attendu 2022 pour y
travailler
puisque c'est l'un des objets du contrat
stratégique de filière de 2002 de 2019
sur la question de la fusion
vous mentionnez une très bonne nouvelle
mais qui est une nouvelle de recherche
puisque c'est une c'est une expérience
de laboratoire
vous aura pas échappé contre
l'expérience de laboratoire et l'objet
industriel livré il peut passer un
certain nombre d'années lorsqu'on
regarde par exemple le projet ITER vous
l'aurez pas la semaine prochaine pour
prendre que cet exemple là d'un projet
qui qui travaille sur sur des sujets
de même nature c'est à l'horizon de la
fin du 21e siècle qui terre devrait
arrivé au terme de ce projet fin du 21e
siècle
à ce stade
monsieur le sénateur montoger
vous m'interrogez sur la baisse de la
puissance installée nucléaire alors je
le redis les réacteurs nucléaires que
nous avons construit avait été construit
pour 40 ans
nous avons passé cette étape de 40 ans
nous sommes aujourd'hui à l'étape de 50
ans nous sommes en train de la passer
pour le moment tous les réacteurs
passent cette étape de 50 ans c'est une
bonne nouvelle
on aurait pu constater des problèmes sur
des cuves qui auraient conduit à ne pas
passer cette étape de 50 ans et lorsque
nous allons passer l'étape de 60 ans ça
sera l'autorisation l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui décidera si
nos installations sont aptes à passer le
cap des 60 ans ce sera pas une décision
politique ce sera pas une décision
technique ce sera une décision de
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui est
un organe indépendant ce qui nous
appartient à nous c'est de travailler
pour être passé dans les meilleures
conditions cette visite des 60 ans
c'est-à-dire
s'assurer un que dans la maintenance
actuelle on prend tous les moyens pour
préserver le capital que nous avons qui
est notre
empreinte industrielle actuelle nous
installations nucléaires actuelles
c'est faire en sorte que c'est
maintenant soient menées dans de bonnes
conditions c'est s'assurer en contrôle
que il n'y a pas
de dérive par rapport à des facteurs
d'usure en particulier sur les pièces
qui sont essentielles parce que vous
avez un problème de corrosion sous
contrainte sur la tuyauterie c'est très
désagréable ça a des centrales il faut
trouver des moyens de réparer mais à la
fin de la journée on remplace la pièce
en revanche remplacer une cuve nucléaire
ça veut dire recommencer à zéro et donc
c'est bien l'enjeu c'est de s'assurer
que les pièces qui sont critiques et non
remplaçables soit capable de passer le
cap des 60 ans c'est pas une décision
politique et c'est encore moi une
volonté politique la volonté politique
c'est de avoir le maximum de durée dans
nos centrales nucléaires et donc
mathématiquement la politique madame
dans cette affaire là on fait le choix
ou on le fait pas elle dépendamment des
possibilités techniques
d'une clarté limpide la clarté limpide
c'est nous ferons le maximum pour que
nos centrales nucléaires soient
prolongées nous ferons le maximum pour
que nos centrales nucléaires soient
prolongées mais s'il y a une fissure sur
une cuve ce sera un élément physique
incontournable le ce qui est intéressant
dans l'énergie c'est qu'il y a des
facteurs des mentionnant qui sont
physiques et que la physique elle
s'impose même aux politiques la parole
performative ça fonctionne pas pour
réparer une cuve nucléaire
voilà et donc vous avez raison de dire
que mécaniquement mais ça c'est pas moi
qui le dis ce sont les scénarios de RTE
mécaniquement dès lors que en 2000 on
n'a pas fait le choix de lancer de vos
réacteurs nucléaires vous avez et oui
vous avez mécaniquement une une
diminution proportionnelle du poids du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique
mais ça c'est la physique et les
mathématiques où c'était décisions
politiques qui auraient fallu prendre il
y a 20 ans
en 2017 ça vous change rien ou assez peu
assez peu non ça change pas
de parole de Golfe collectivement
on va je vais donner la parole à
Jean-Michel Houlgate
merci monsieur le Président donc tous
mes vœux madame la ministre on va
souhaiter une belle année énergétique
pour pour 2023 ma question est très
rapide quels sont les gains qui sont
véritablement attendus par ce projet de
loi et puis j'aurais peut-être une
remarque extrêmement rapide également
vous avez compris que que ceux de lait
de 15 ans est soumis à interrogation il
a besoin d'être objectivé dans la mesure
où normalement en 2023 il y aura donc la
stratégie française climat énergie il y
aura la PPE donc en 2024 on y verra
claire il y aura une planification donc
on sera en capacité d'une certaine façon
de pouvoir revenir à un rythme nominal
de procédure donc 15 ans ont besoin
d'être pour nous objectiver
merci mes chers collègues en raison des
contraintes de la commission du
développement durable je leur laisse
poser les questions de ceux qui veulent
poser on prend plus d'inscription en
revanche parce que sinon ça sera voilà
et ensuite madame la ministre pourra
répondre merci
la parole est gold
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente à la ministre moi je serais
très rapide car mon intervention est
plutôt d'ordre général actuellement un
certain nombre de centrales nucléaires
sont exploités à proximité des fleuves
afin de bénéficier d'eau en quantité
suffisante pour refroidir le réacteur
intervention un rapport par rapport avec
le débat qui avait l'air et dans
l'hémicycle les sécheresses successives
de ces dernières années ayant impacté de
faire son considérables les débit de nos
fleuves et les températures de l'eau
ayant refroidis réacteurs menacent la
biodiversité donc en aval or les
conflits d'usage autour du partage de
l'eau montrent l'enjeu autour de cette
ressource après plusieurs années de
sécheresse les spécialistes ayant même
mesuré 2022 comme l'année la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée dans ces conditions
comment assurer à la fois le
refroidissement des nouvelles
installations quand l'eau vient à
manquer sans menacer les autres usages
merci la parole est en Martinique oui
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre bonne année également je
voulais
dire en même temps que je tenais à
saluer la décision qui avait été prise
de maintenir la centrale de Gravelines
et de l'équiper de nouveaux réacteurs de
de nouveau réacteurs nouvelle génération
mais en même temps cela ne m'empêche pas
de m'interroger sur une question qui me
semble fondamentale à savoir les déchets
radioactifs comme beaucoup de citoyens
d'ailleurs dans le débat public il
remonte que c'est la question majeure
qui se pose et qui est posée par les
citoyens donc je voulais vous demander
si vous prévoyez de disséminer ou de
rassembler de la même manière les sites
de gestion des déchets que que pour les
sites nucléaires en effet
cette question même si votre texte est
technique il pose néanmoins un certain
nombre de sujets et de sujets de
important je vous remercie de bien
vouloir
la parole est en jeu prévue merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
meilleurs vœux également donc je vais
abonder dans les deux questions qui ont
déjà été posées parce que c'était sont
les questions que je voulais poser alors
d'abord fonctionnement d'une centrale
nucléaire besoin d'eau absolument
nécessaire donc comment fait-on avec des
sécheresses et des la plus vieux métrie
qui diminue et notamment en Occitanie où
c'est déjà acté moins 20% plusvométrie
et dans les années à venir certainement
encore moins donc comment fait-on et là
il ne s'agit pas juste de la gestion des
usages c'est juste un élément hyper
important et qui et qui nécessiterait
une mise à l'arrêt d'une centrale si
nous n'avons pas soit assez d'eau soit
la température trop élevée de l'eau ce
qui est le cas de la Garonne tous les
étés et concernant la gestion des
déchets c'est également on arrive au
bout en saturation des déchets qui sont
stockés en surface et nous n'avons pas
encore commencé le stockage et fichiers
à Bures donc comment peut-on envisager
un tel programme alors que deux
problématiques importantes qui sont en
train d'émerger qu'on n'avait pas bien
évidemment au début du programme
nucléaire sont là
la parole est Gilbert lutte merci merci
monsieur le Président merci madame la
ministre de vos éclairages j'ai déjà
d'une précision c'est nouveau réacteurs
seront installés à priori sur des sites
existants s'agit-il de capacité
nucléaires qui viendront en substitution
des réacteurs actuels ou s'agit-il de
capacité de production nucléaire
supplémentaires et dans ce cas là
faudra-t-il en déployer de nouvelles
lignes électriques pour les raccorder
pour raccorder ces nouveaux réacteurs je
ne reviens pas sur la question de l'eau
du refroidissement l'état abordé et un
deuxième aspect qui a été soulevé me
semble-t-il par nos rapporteurs ces
projets fonctionneront
à partir pour mieux à partir de 2035
pour une soixantaine d'années comment
est envisagé étudié penser les aspects
de sûreté de sécurité dans le contexte
d'un changement qui pratique qui
s'accompagne d'événements extrêmes
nouveaux dont on a peu ou pas la
connaissance en 203
merci la parole est à Étienne blanc
merci Monsieur prudent le ministre
aujourd'hui se développe des
technologies nouvelles en Amérique du
Nord en Europe du Nord en Italie en
France aussi notamment une société qui
s'appelle nucléo qui utilise le plomb
liquide qui règle les problèmes de
refroidissement et qui règle notamment
en grande partie des problèmes de
production de déchets qu'avez-vous prévu
dans ce texte pour accompagner une
filière privée qui semble aller
désormais beaucoup plus rapidement que
ne va EDF sur cette technologie nouvelle
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de madame la ministre vous
avez souvent présenté dans votre exposé
le motif comme un élément fondateur de
la politique énergétique de la France et
notre position est claire au Sénat ici
en faveur d'une stratégie énergie
d'anticipation et de prévisions qui dans
un cas au pays pour notre indépendance
énergétique et une sécurisation de notre
production je rappelle ici qu'il y a
deux ans jour pour jour le 12 janvier
2021 nous tenions débat public initié
par notre groupe sur le risque de
blackout énergétique de la France par
manque de stratégie un risque qui s'est
imposé cet hiver donc nous appelons
depuis des mois une politique
énergétique sans enterrement donc moi
j'avais une question j'avais trois
questions premièrement pourquoi
proposez-vous une approche de la
politique énergétique de la France en
silo nous l'avons déjà regretté lors de
l'examen du projet de loi relative à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable dans lesquelles
vous n'avez pas traité
l'hydroélectricité et légiférer
directeur sacrifie l'objectif de
planification auquel nous devons
collectivement répondre j'avais deux
questions
premièrement à quoi ce projet de loi
sert-il légiférer sur des mesures
d'adaptation des procédures
administratives oui mais quand
allons-nous discuter d'un projet de loi
stratégie et débattre des orientations
choisies par le gouvernement et la
deuxième question il faudrait pas que
l'hydroélectricité connaisse le sort du
nucléaire après lequel on court
désormais alors que nous étions à la
pointe de cette technologie et que l'on
a abandonné par idéologie renoncement
cette question est pour moi essentielle
car l'hydroélectricité en France depuis
trop longtemps laissé dans une situation
juridique qui ne permet pas d'investir
massivement sur des solutions innovantes
d'avenir et d'optimiser la capacité de
production de nos barrages or ce sont
des infrastructures existantes qui ne
demandent qu'à être exploité les
barrages représentent un jugement
essentiel pour le mix énergétique
notamment en Aveyron dans la vallée de
l'hôtellerie
aussi que prévoit le gouvernement
concernant la régularisation de la mise
en concession des barrages EDF pour que
l'entreprise puisse enfin mettre en
oeuvre le plan de monter en puissance et
qu'elle propose depuis des années et
l'investissement stratégique dans les
technologies de stockage je vous
remercie
pour terminer oui merci Monsieur
président bonne année madame la ministre
vous avez dit tout à l'heure quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup intéressé vous a
dit qu'on a on avait des entreprises qui
seraient donc intéressés pour pour
signer je pense des contrats long terme
à 100 euros le mégawattheure donc on
sera vers 2037 2040 un moment où en
Europe
les pays du Nord seront exportateurs
d'électricité de grand éolien à 60 euros
et les pays du Sud c'est déjà le cas du
Portugal de photovoltique entre 30 et 40
euros donc je voulais juste savoir sur
quel rapport de l'État qui ont produit
on a des rapports sérieux de RTE de
l'ADEME déjà qui montre que un scénario
100% renouvelable fonctionne mais et sur
quel rapport de l'état de la Cour des
comptes je ne sais de quel grand
organisme d'état vous vous appuyez pour
pouvoir comme ça considérer qu'on aura
des acheteurs à 100 euros le mégawatt
heure en 2040 et est-ce qu'on pourrait
nous aussi avoir ce rapport qui vous
permet de justifier votre affirmation
merci alors je vous montre
à ces questions avant que la commission
des affaires économiques répondent
donc première élément sur le sur le
délai de 15 ans et son objectif à Sion
je le redis si c'est le délai de 15 ans
de construction dont on parle je trouve
aussi que c'est trop long
mais c'est ce qui ressort des deux
audits externes qui ont été demandés par
le gouvernement en 2019 et 2022
donc c'est ce que je redis sur l'énergie
à un moment la réalité physique et la
réalité
des mathématiques s'imposent et
industrielles s'impose aussi à chacun
leur l'enjeu c'est comment le réduire
c'est l'enjeu de ce projet de loi
c'est-à-dire que pour le coup on
s'attaque à toute la dimension
administrative permit du de ce projet
c'est la question de la formation c'est
la question la formation dont je dis
qu'elle est accompagnée depuis désormais
plus de deux ans puisque c'est depuis
2019 que nous avons des actions pour
renforcer la formation et la montée en
compétences de la filière et c'est
l'accompagnement de la sous-traitance et
là encore depuis 2019 contrat
stratégique de filière signée de mémoire
au mois de mai ou juin 2019
nous avons accompagné la sous-traitance
en montée en compétences et nous l'avons
fait dans le plan de relance et nous
avons également une ligne dans dans
France 2030
sur ensuite la question de l'eau la
question de l'eau elle est évidemment
prise en compte dans les dossiers
d'autorisation de construction je
rappelle d'ailleurs que les deux
premières paires de réacteurs sont
construites en bordure de littoral et
que donc l'enjeu se positionne d'une
manière un petit peu différente de celle
qui sont construites des réacteurs qui
seront construits en bordure de rivière
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que cet enjeu de lot
va être déterminant notamment dans le
choix de l'implantation de vos réacteurs
c'est un des éléments qui va conduire
EDF à nous faire des recommandations
pour tel site plutôt que tel autre site
là aussi il y aura une vision politique
mais il y aura la physique qui
s'imposera à tout le monde si on veut
faire des projets de qualité donc c'est
bien pris en compte s'agissant des des
déchets comme vous le savez
madame la sénatrice vous avez raison de
souligner que c'est effectivement le
point c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
observe une évolution assez sensible de
la population qui est man un soutien au
nucléaire mais qui s'interroge sur la
manière dont on traite les déchets et
c'est leur principal point de de
sensibilité puisque sur la sécurité il y
a certains points qui
comment dire manifester dans les
réunions mais qui est manifesté en
disant mais on a le sentiment que c'est
traité sur les déchets en matière de
dangerosité les déchets de faible et
très faible activité c'est 91% des
volumes produits pour moins de 0,05% de
la radioactivité totale les déchets les
plus dangereux c'est 3% du volume pour
plus de 99% de la radioactivité totale
donc première élément c'est pas tous les
déchets enfin en tout cas il y a une
réponse qui est adaptée par type de
déchets et évidemment ceux qui sont les
plus problématiques ou ceux qui doivent
susciter la question ce sont ces 3% du
volume
vous savez que nous avons un plan
national de gestion des matières et des
déchets radioactifs que je viens de
signer le cinquième plan a été publié en
décembre 2022 il couvre la période 2022
2026 vous savez également que nous avons
un travail qui est mené avec sigeo
j'ai signé la Déclaration d'Utilité
Publique et nous sommes dans la phase de
dossiers d'autorisation de construction
si géo c'est un site qui présente des
caractéristiques géologiques dont notre
laboratoire est capable de montrer que
depuis plus de 300000 ans
géologiquement ce site n'a pas évolué et
donc étape a priori à
stocker des déchets dont la
radioactivité est importante à 300
mètres en profondeur dans le sol et avec
une un niveau de sécurité qui est
considéré comme maximal ce n'est pas une
démarche individuelle la France vous
avez d'autres projets comme ça à
l'international où on va regarder quels
sont les endroits qui géologiquement
sont le mieux adaptés à ce type de
stockage et donc nous avons une solution
qui se dessine pour le stockage des
déchets les plus radiotifs nous devons
également traiter le sujet de la Hague
et nous avons enfin tout un travail qui
est mené sur le cycle du combustible
puisque une des réponses à la question
que c'est que vous posez c'est aussi le
fait d'avoir un de recycler le maximum
de la part des déchets que nous
utilisons et aujourd'hui nous sommes en
appui dorano pour développer plus avancé
ses capacités en la matière
madame la sénatrice Préville vous
m'autorisera à penser que j'ai déjà
répondu à vos deux questions sur l'eau
et les déchets vous posez une question
sur puisque je viens de les évoquer
l'une derrière l'autre sur les
raccordements et là vous avez raison de
souligner qui dura un enjeu d'adaptation
du réseau de transport à la fois au
regard de changement climatique et à la
fois au regard de désinstallations
complémentaires que l'on pourrait mettre
ça fait effectivement partie mais de
manière générale la question de
l'adaptation du réseau de transport va
être essentiel puisque si nous allons
faire une diminution de notre
consommation d'énergie totale mais une
augmentation importante de notre
consommation d'électricité les réseaux
de transport et les réseaux de
distribution vont devoir être adaptés de
manière importante et d'ailleurs en
tenant compte aussi du fait que vous
aurez des grandes unités de production
mais vous allez avoir une diversité de
petite unités de production sur le
territoire ce qui change la logique de
ces réseaux
sur la question de
des modèles plomb sodium self fondue
donc je veux vous rassurer nous avons au
travers de France 2030 des projets qui
sont vers à toutes les technologies de
réacteurs innovants y compris de rupture
de rupture
et que un projet comme nucléo a été
invité à participer pardon à cet appel à
cet appel à projet donc c'est la ligne
que je mentionnais qui est de 1,2
milliards d'euros je me suis un petit
peu emballé c'est pas 2 milliards
d'euros c'est 1,2 milliards d'euros de
soutien dans France 2030 pour
accompagner ces projets qui sont
aujourd'hui à une phase de maturité
relativement modeste mais dont on espère
que
l'intérêt que nous observe dans
l'ensemble dans beaucoup de pays
européens et en dehors d'Europe va
contribuer à accélérer la mise en oeuvre
concrète et évidemment moi j'ai très
clairement dit et à Joël bar et à
l'ucrémont qu'il fallait être très
attentif aux évolutions des technologies
sur le marché pour être prêt à s'en
saisir lorsqu'on en aurait
la preuve de concept
sur Youtube bon pourquoi alors je
rappelle que le projet de loi ENR traite
bien de l'hydroélectricité peut-être pas
de tout mais il y a bien des mesures sur
l'hydroélectricité quand va-t-on
débattre je le redis nous allons
débattre cet été sur un projet de loi
qui portera sur notre stratégie énergie
climat
et l'hydroélectricité fait-elle bien
partie de notre mix énergétique puisque
jamais nous avons d'ailleurs
l'intervention d'investir et ça sera un
des objets de la loi énergique climat
que nous vous présenterons
monsieur le sénateur Dantec vous êtes
taquin parce qu'il y a aucun moment j'ai
dit que les entreprises
sont intéressées pour signer des
contrats à 100 euros du meilleur water
en 2040
en 2040 j'ai dit qu'aujourd'hui si vous
leur proposez de signer un contrat à 100
euros du mégawattheure de long terme et
en intégrant la question des énergies
fossiles c'est effectivement
un positionnement c'est ce qu'elle me
dit ce n'est pas un rapport ni la Cour
des comptes ni d'autres instances non
écrit sur ce sujet peut-être écrit mais
en tout cas moi c'est ce que me disent
les entreprises c'est à dire qu'elles
cherchent à positionner des contrats de
long terme c'est très exactement ce
qu'on fait avec les pipi et
c'est l'enjeu
enfin c'est un des éléments de réforme
du marché l'électricité c'est à dire de
donner des contrats qui soient sur la
base des coûts de production plus marge
et puis vous aura pas échappé un petit
détail mais vous me voyez venir
l'électricité nucléaire est pilotable
l'électricité renouvelable ne l'est pas
totalement et donc vous pouvez
effectivement avoir un enjeu d'assurance
qui fait que
l'intérêt d'industriel pour le nucléaire
pourraient être plus en tout cas tout
aussi avéré voire parfois plus et voir
il pourrait souhaiter avoir un mix
énergétique qui leur permet d'avoir à la
fois les mérites de renouvelables et les
mérites du nucléaire il me semble que
c'est dans cette direction par exemple
que France industrie que j'ai réuni en
fait qui m'a accueilli hier soir
fonctionne et résonne à moyen terme
très bien monsieur le Président je vous
libère pour ne vous libérons pour vos
obligations ainsi que les commissaires
de la mission des développements durable
merci beaucoup
on fait juste un petit bac de 30
secondes pour gérer le bruit et le
départ de nos collègues et ensuite on
attaque
juste je précise puisque madame ma
filleule part madame filleul j'ai juste
une précision donc le la question du
recyclage est bien traitée dans la loi
énergie climat
des déchets ça fait partie des éléments
allez on continue notre commission tu
vas bien
bonne année à toi merci beaucoup
oui j'ai vu ça
mes collègues de la commission du
développement durable voilà
gérer leur départ dans la discrétion
monsieur Dantec
monsieur Dantec parce que je vais donner
la parole à Fabien gay donc merci
merci beaucoup donc la question suivante
et je vous donne du coup un petit peu
plus de temps donc pas parce que parce
qu'on en a moins de contraintes c'est
Fabien gay
et ensuite Bernard lui bonjour à toutes
et tous madame la président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues bonne année
à tout le monde non moi juste une
question ça je me demande pourquoi ce
projet de loi maintenant madame la
ministre parce que pour le coup vous
avez raison le nucléaire c'est du temps
long 15 20 25 ans de construction 40 60
ans d'exploitation
vous avez dit qu'il y a tout un tas de
questions qui seront dans la PPE et vous
commencez à y répondre parce que vous
êtes obligé de faire la politique parce
que c'est un texte extrêmement technique
mais en même temps on veut faire de la
politique quel financement
quelle filière industrielle quelle
formation est-ce que et d'ailleurs votre
réponse à la question de Daniel et
intéressante et vous le dites sur la
régulation qui va payer est-ce que c'est
EDF mais si ce EDF est-ce que ça va
rester dans l'arène quelle régulation
bon donc on a beaucoup de questions de
débat
qui pour le coup devrait nous occuper
maintenant et après avoir un texte
technique moi je me demande et je donc
je vous repose cette question simple
pourquoi cet empressement un test un
texte extrêmement technique qui va
raccourcir les délais de quelques
semaines ou quelques mois sauf sur une
partie sur les évidemment s'il y a
contestation alors qu'on devrait d'abord
avoir le débat politique voilà
je m'interroge depuis le début sur cet
empressement là à avoir ce texte
ultra technique de 10 articles je vous
remercie merci
Fabien Bernard Guy ensuite Sylviane Noël
merci présidente madame la ministre
alors que le projet de loi a présenté
concerne également le fonctionnement des
installations existantes ou en
sommes-nous sur la remise en service du
parc existant et ma deuxième question
portera sur la stratégie nucléaire lors
d'une récente table ronde organisée par
notre commission le président dorano
projet Guillaume Durot appelé à définir
une stratégie d'ensemble couvrant
également l'amant donc
l'approvisionnement combustible et
l'aval la gestion des déchets de la
production nucléaire de la même manière
le président de l'ASM a indiqué qu'il
serait pertinent de traiter la
problématique de la prolongation du parc
existant considérant que les trois
quarts du parc nucléaire daté des années
80 ce qui provoquera un effet falaise
sur leur fin de vie cette stratégie
d'ensemble sera-t-elle intégrée à la loi
de programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie
merci Bernard Silviane Noël merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre je me
permets de rebondir sur la question de
mon collègue Jean-Claude anglar car je
pense que vous n'avez pas complètement
répondu à son interrogation sur un point
qui me semble-t-il dépasse largement le
chant de la future loi en air la crise
énergétique que nous vivons aujourd'hui
ne devrait-elle pas conduire le
gouvernement français à afficher très
fermement à l'égard de nos partenaires
européens notre opposition à l'ouverture
à la concurrence des barrages
hydroélectriques qui aujourd'hui sont
assurés à 80% par EDF et qui pourrait
conduire un morcellement du marché
préjudiciable à la filière je vous
remercie
merci Sylviane Évelyne Renaud garabédian
merci Madame président de Madame
ministre une question sur la sûreté des
centrales nucléaires qui est une
priorité absolue de nouvelles menaces
sont apparues ces dernières années sur
les infrastructures notamment en raison
des fortes tensions géopolitiques que
nous connaissons cet été l'autorité
britannique de réglementation nucléaire
a placé les infrastructures de DF sur
son territoire sous viligence ont
renforcé pour étudier la politique qui a
été mise en place en matière de
cybersécurité par le DF pouvez-vous nous
indiquer comment vous intégrer ces
nouveaux risques dans le cadre du projet
de loi que vous présentez merci merci
Evelyne et enfin Anne-Catherine Loisier
merci Madame la prison madame mamie sur
une petite question en fait sur le
foncier des de ces nouveaux sites
s'agit-il de si déjà artificialisé et si
ce n'est pas le cas vous comprenez le
sens de ma question quel sera leur
traitement dans le cadre de la stratégie
merci dans les amendements du rapporteur
très bien et il y a d'autres questions
je n'en vois pas donc Madame la Ministre
voilà
alors
monsieur le sénateur gay
la ce texte il est important pour parce
que en fait on a analysé la conduite du
projet de nouvelles centrales nucléaires
en faisant un rétroplanning et donc le
dossier administratif et les dossiers de
permis de construire doivent être
adaptés dès maintenant si on veut
effectivement livrer des réacteurs
nucléaires dans 15 ans là aussi
c'est ce sont des dossiers qui prennent
plusieurs années ce projet de loi est
permis de gagner plusieurs années et lui
a coulé du premier béton si on veut
tenir cet objectif de couler du premier
béton à 5 ans ça suppose que ce projet
de loi soit adopté avant la fin du
premier semestre ça c'est une réalité
qui est également une réalité physique
et je dirais de
de conduite de projets donc moi je
prends mes responsabilités en tant que
ministre et je ne l'ai pas en que les
projets et je ne mets pas en risque les
projets même pour faire de la belle
politique je ne vais pas en risque les
projets peut-être ma limite de personnes
issues de la société civile mais c'est
peut-être aussi ma fierté
ça c'est le premier point vous aurez
effectivement un débat sur le devenir de
la régulation de l'arène puisque c'est
la Commission européenne qui est pas la
Commission européenne mais la Reine se
termine en 2025 donc par construction il
y a un schéma de régulation post-arrête
qui doit être négocié avec
avec la Commission européenne et je
rappelle que sur le ce qu'on appelle le
design de marché de l'électricité un
certain nombre de positions a été prise
par la France qui ont été très clairs
notamment sur
l'intérêt de découpler le marché j'ai
fait du gage du marché d'électricité sur
l'intérêt d'avoir des consommateurs qui
payent un prix qui reflète plus
précisément ou plus objectivement la
réalité de leur mix énergétique et la
Commission européenne a mis sur la table
comme on conseille de l'énergie de du 19
décembre un premier papier qui va dans
ce sens avec l'utilisation de contrats
par différents et de pipi comme élément
qui peuvent nous aider à
mieux régler le marché l'électricité
néanmoins quand vous avez un besoin
enfin quand votre demande d'électricité
augmente il est assez logique que
la centrale qui est la plus coûteuse
fixe le prix et qu'elle ne produise pas
à fond perdu c'est une règle c'est
classique de ne pas vendre c'est même
interdit je crois en France de vendre en
dessous du prix de de production donc en
fait c'est la logique de ce marché aussi
et quand on est importateur
d'électricité à certains moments de
l'année et bien on paye le prix de ces
importations ça c'est aussi une règle
assez classique pour une parfaite de son
utilisation oui mais c'est en règle
générale on les importe les jours on en
a le plus besoin c'est à dire ou le prix
le plus élevé
sur la question de la remise en service
du parc existant nous sommes aujourd'hui
après de 45 gigawatts qui ont été mis
sur le réseau c'est-à-dire l'objectif
effectivement que
RTE avait pris en compte dans ces
scénarios
de passage de l'hiver avec 44 réacteurs
en fonctionnement je rappelle que
ça fait donc
12 réacteurs qui sont arrêtés
aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'on avait 32
réacteurs arrêtés au mois d'août donc
vous voyez que le calendrier de remise
en route des secteur
avance nous avons aujourd'hui
deux trois réacteurs qui devraient donc
dans le décalage est maintenant à peu
près clair plutôt du côté de Mars mais
pour le reste nous tenons la la remise
en route des réacteurs et il n'y a pas
de risque d'approvisionnement à court
terme mais je crois que ça chacun a
construit compris et notamment du fait
de l'impact du plan sobriété qui permet
l'économie grosso modo de cette réacteur
je crois que j'ai tout
stratégie d'ensemble ah oui pardon sur
la sécurité et la cyber sécurité je suis
en train de prendre des arrêtés sécurité
alors
la sûreté c'est
l'installation nucléaire dans ses effets
du fait du nucléaire la sécurité c'est
les risques par exemple terrorisme qui
pourrait
survenir et dont il faut prendre en
compte mais qui sont pas liés à au
caractère particulier l'installation ce
sont des risques génériques pour tout
installation sensible donc sur la
sécurité la cyber sécurité je suis en
train de finaliser des arrêtés sécurité
pour le nucléaire pour rehausser le
niveau de sécurité et de cybersécurité
de chaque installation ça vaut pour les
centrales nucléaires ça vaut pour les
laboratoires de recherche le projet de
loi ne modifiera pas le cadre en matière
et de sécurité et de sûreté je le
précise
au-delà des mesures de sécurisation pour
la SN sur le travail de
décision de d'extension de
l'exploitation que nous prenons sur la
base des recommandations la scène fait
de recommandations et nous prenons la
décision finale
je crois que j'ai tout dit et évidemment
la stratégie d'ensemble Hamon aval sera
examiné dans la loi énergie climat
sur tes décentrales ça je l'ai dit sur
l'artificialisation des sols madame la
sénatrice Loisel je partage sur le fond
mais on a un projet de loi dédié à au
zéro artificialisation nette je crois
que vous y êtes d'ailleurs assez
contributeur si c'est bien suivi les
débats c'est donc notre proposition de
traiter cela dans le texte sinon chaque
texte va arriver on dira les énergies
renouvelables sortent du SAN le
nucléaire sort du zan l'industrie sort
du zen et à la fin on aura un problème
d'addition donc je pense qu'il faut
avoir une vision globale du Zéro
artificialisation net évidemment vu du
point de vue du ministère de la
transition énergétique c'est plus
confortable d'avoir des facilités
et sur l'hydraulique de notre point de
vue aussi
sur sur l'hydraulique je reviens à ce
sujet
nous nous avons une position qui
qui est très claire c'est de
s'assurer que nos barrages électriques
soient
exploité avec le la meilleure
performance industrielle et
opérationnelle ce qui explique les
positions que nous avons pris nous
allons prolonger la concession de la CNR
point important nous sommes en train de
travailler avec le nouveau patron de DF
sur la stratégie de DF dont les
prochaines années le sujet des droits
électricité est posé il y a plusieurs
solutions et je souhaite qu'il nous
fasse des propositions avant que de si
on a besoin d'un texte de loi de vous le
proposer ou de d'aller de l'avant et de
négocier les bonnes options
avec avec la Commission européenne nous
notre objectif et c'est un des enjeux de
la loi énergie climat c'est
effectivement de pouvoir investir de
nouveaux enfin de faire de nouveaux
investissements dans les steps et les
montées en puissance des barrages
hydraulique on sait qu'on est à peu près
6 milliards d'euros d'investissement
pour améliorer de 20 à 30% la puissance
de nos barrages dans un contexte où à
l'inverse le réchauffement climatique
fait une pression sur les capacités
potentielles le production de ces
barrages donc je dirais que la ligne est
assez claire à ce sujet
très bien y a-t-il d'autres questions
d'autres interrogations oui pierre louer
tout simplement l'énergie nucléaire a
besoin de beaucoup d'eau est-ce vraiment
compatible avec une politique
environnementale qui tend à baisser le
niveau des nappes et des cours d'eau
depuis un certain nombre d'années en
supprimant tous les barrages sur les
ruisseaux rivières et fleuves voilà tout
simplement ma question
d'abord le nucléaire n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup d'eau le nucléaire a besoin
d'eau pour
le refroidissement et le sujet qui est
posé c'est pas la quantité d'eau puisque
qui est accessible dans nos rivières
pour le moment et même avec des
scénarios climatiques et même dans le
cadre par exemple de l'hiver le sujet
qui est posé c'est le rejet par la
centrale nucléaire de l'eau dans son
circuit de refroidissement qui a une
température légèrement supérieure à
celle de l'eau qui circule dans le
ruisseau la rivière etc on parle de
quelques dixièmes de degré parfois moi
j'ai signé des dérogations qui ont pu
aller jusqu'à 1 degré supérieur par
rapport au cadre
existant et nous notre sujet c'est celui
de la biodiversité c'est pas vous voyez
bien que pour
la question qui nous amène à encadrer
ces rejets c'est pour éviter d'avoir un
impact sur la biodiversité de ses cours
d'eau et
qui nous amène à
piloter effectivement ces dérogations et
nous faisons un suivi systématique de la
biodiversité de la phonée de la flore
non seulement on continue mais par
rapport à au dérogations qu'on a été
amené à signer pour vérifier
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas d'impact
nuisible à la biodiversité dans le dans
le dans le reflux je rappelle que les
centrales ne
consomment très peu d'eau infidée
puisque 98% de l'eau prélevée restituée
au milieu naturel donc c'est
c'est l'économie circulaire
allez une dernière petite question de
Martine Berthet oui merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre j'aimerais
revenir sur le sujet des compétences
nous allons commencer mission
d'information avec la délégation aux
entreprises là-dessus et même si vous
avez répondu à deux questions qui ont
été posées tout de même pouvez-vous nous
dire à quel délai dans quel
délai de temps vous pensez à voir
pouvoir réunir suffisamment de
compétences humaines pour mener à bien
ses projets parce qu'on est là sur un
projet de loi qui est pour accélérer la
mise en oeuvre du nucléaire la remise en
oeuvre du nucléaire mais en fait il va
vous manquer le principal tout de même
les compétences humaines même si vous
nous dites que depuis 2019 vous avez
vous êtes penché sur le sujet
alors je le redis la première coulée de
béton elle est en 2027 qui appelle les
compétences de génie civil
l'un des enjeux qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir une gestion prévisionnelle
des emplois et des compétences avec
d'un côté les sorties
de des entreprises qui travaillent dans
le secteur nucléaire c'est-à-dire les
départs à la retraite éventuellement les
transferts à d'autres secteurs mais il y
a plutôt un maintien des personnes qui
travaillent de leucléaire font leur
carrière dans le nucléaire parce que il
y a un élément de d'intérêt et de
passion de ces métiers
donc d'un côté la sortie de l'autre côté
les besoins et la croissance des besoins
mais aussi avec le cadencement les
soudeurs je vais pas les en avoir besoin
la semaine prochaine les ingénieurs pour
toute la partie design effectivement
seront les bienvenus et assez vite
puisque nous avons à la fois les projets
de
maintenant je dirais de gestion courante
des centrales nucléaires aux meilleurs
standard vous savez que nous avons un
audit qui démontre qu'on peut gagner en
moyenne un mois sur la les arrêts de
tranche et qui donc
nous invite à réfléchir à un certain
nombre de
méthodes à mettre en œuvre ce que va
faire EDF ça va prendre deux à trois ans
mais derrière il y a des besoins de
compétences vous avez ensuite la
préparation de la prolongation
d'exploitation
décentrales nucléaires qui est un
travail absolument massif qui se qui
démarre en règle générale quatre cinq
ans avant la visite
organisée et qui suppose une
documentation très importante d'une part
et qui va supposer aussi c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure autant que
possible et en essayant de mieux croiser
les expertises par exemple avec le CEA
de regarder si même dans la gestion
qu'on rentre on peut pas s'assurer en
anticipation d'avoir la meilleure
maintenance possible pour pouvoir faire
durer les centrales nucléaires le plus
longtemps possible et puis vous avez le
programme nouveau nucléaire donc on
empile trois objets qui sont absolument
essentiels pour la tenue de notre
de notre trajectoire énergétique
c'est donc plus 40% d'effectifs d'ici
et mon premier enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
une question d'attractivité des métiers
c'est comment remplir les sections de
bac pro de soudeur d'électro technicien
de mécanicien etc c'est ça le premier
objectif c'est tout l'enjeu d'ailleurs
de la réforme du lycée professionnel on
creuse comment on arrive à avoir
l'appareil de formation le mieux adapté
aux besoins et derrière comment on
arrive à ce que cet appareil de
formation accueille le mieux possible
des jeunes qui soient au courant de ces
métiers j'ai porté cette casquette avec
l'industrie pendant quatre ans avant
avoir la charge de la transition
énergétique c'est une question
récurrente comment amène-t-on des jeunes
qui ne sont pas exposés familialement au
métier de l'industrie et plus
spécifiquement aux métiers du nucléaire
a considérer ces carrières alors que
le la perception partagée dans les
médias dans ce qu'on lit c'est que
l'industrie l'usine ce sont pas des
endroits on gagne bien sa vie ou on a
les conditions de travail correct etc
donc c'est ce regard là qu'il faut aussi
changer et sur lequel la question va
bien au-delà des sujets de compétences
vous avez raison de souligner que ce
sujet de compétences est majeur puisque
plus 40% d'effectifs c'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait c'est intéressant
néanmoins dans un projet d'entreprise
c'est que vous avez quand même peu de
projets d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
disent on a un énorme projet industriel
à porter et Bonne Nouvelle on va
recruter plein de gens pour le porter je
pense que ça c'est une un élément de
mobilisation des équipes de déesse et de
fierté en interne peut-être ça sera
aussi enjeu de cumul emploi retraite
pour les équipes du secteur en tout cas
moi je compte aussi sur les deux entrées
les deux bouts de la filière des jeunes
et ceux qui arriveront à la retraite et
dont on peut penser que on aura encore
besoin des compétences et qu'il faudra
réfléchir à une façon de les comment
dire prendre avec nous s'il le souhaite
le plus longtemps possible et vraiment
pour finir Franck Menonville parce
qu'après on doit laisser partir madame
la ministre
Franck oui madame la Présidente une
question extrêmement rapide quand
surviendront la surviendra la l'annonce
et dans quelle temporalité du choix des
sites il y a eu des premières annonces
et il y aura comment on va se décliner
ce calendrier
alors les les deux premiers sites ont
été effectivement annoncés le troisième
site est sur le Rhône là il y a des
analyses qui sont faites pour prendre en
compte les questions qu'on que je
mentionnais notamment
la question de
l'adéquation de ces sites avec
quels sont les réserves foncières
quelles sont les enjeux de
refroidissement quels sont les enjeux de
sécurité quels sont les enjeux de bassin
d'emploi enfin c'est tous ces éléments
qui sont considérés pour que EDF nous
fasse la meilleure proposition et sur la
base des pour et contre de ces sites
tranchera et puis
sur les huit sites à venir on a à peine
au démarrage de du scénario donc pour le
moment c'est pas une décision de cette
année
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
ministre d'avoir répondu à ses premières
questions je vous donne rendez-vous
bientôt dans l'hémicycles la semaine
prochaine pour voilà examiner ce texte
en séance je vous remercie donc je vous
souhaite un bon conseil des ministres et
en attendant je vous propose à mes
collègues de vous retrouver en salle des
affaires économiques voilà pour
commencer dans 10 minutes notre
commission et notamment l'examen des
amendements sur ce texte et la
présentation du rapport